بعد ان اعلن تموزكم ليلا عن الحد الادنى
للتفاوض بشان الحرب في اوكرانيا وهو
الاعتراف بضم المناطق الاربعه ها هي موسكو
تغذكييف صباحا على اصوات انفجارات طالت
العاصمه ومعظمه مدن البلاد بصوارخ كاليبر
واس 300 اطلقت من البحر الاسود وبحر ازوف
وشبه جزيره القرم بلغ عددها 64 صاروخا دمر
الدفاع الجوي الاوكراني منها 54 صاروخا
بالنسبه بلغ الثمانيه
بالمئه وهي نسبه اعتبرها القائد العام
للقوات المسلحه الاخرانيه الجنرال فاليري
زولوجي نسبه جيده جدا من نظري الى حجم
البلاد
الابواب خلعت الان نفكر فيما يمكننا ان
نفعله المنزل بارد جدا ويجب ان نجد حالا
كنا في المنزل عندما حدث ذلك اخذت الطفل
بسرعه الى القبو حدث انفجارين لقد كان ذلك
امورعبا كنته خائفا على الاطفال كان نصيب
العاصمه من القصف الروسي صباح اليوم 16
صاروخا اسقطتها جميعا انظمه دفاع المدينه
الا بعد الشظايا طالت بعض احيائها على
غرار دار مسكين بينما سقطت قذيفه على قريه
دمارا كبيرا حيث اقف الان جميع المباني
المحيطه دمر بشكل كامل او جزئي كما اصيب
ثلاثه اشخاص ونقلوا لتلقي الرعايه الصحيه
ويواصل عمال الانقاذ يرفع الانقاذ والبحث
عنه
لقد سقطت هنا قذيفه واصيبت امراه واخذوها
الى المستشفى لاجراء عمليه وهناك طفله في
الرابعه عشره من عمرها اصيبت ايضا وجميع
المنازل
تضررتها
في الجنوب وخاركيف وسومي وبلطافا في الشرق
في الشمال وحتى اقصى الغرب الاوكراني
مدينه الفيف لم تسلم فال 90% من المدينه
دون كهرباء او ميه 140% من كيف على ذات
الحال ومعظم مدن اوكرانيا تعاني من فقدان
هذه الخدمات الاساسيه نتيجه هذا القصف
وليس عادل العربي العربيه كيف